what's up guys and welcome to a video
that I'm really damn happy to make a
video on the Dark Souls 2 interview on
the 11th of April I think it's safe to
say that everyone in the Dark Souls
community was worried for the sequel all
it took was one little quote just one
little quote that went like this we want
to make the game more accessible and
immediately people started visualizing
this and that was all it took for many
in the community to give up completely
the amount of overreaction was
ridiculous but I like to think that
people overreacted because they feel so
passionately about the game they didn't
want to see their favorite franchise
ruined and this is why I'm happy to make
this video if you don't end up watching
any further at least know this
everything we've seen in the gameplay
reveal everything we've heard from the
developers this April looks and sounds
[ __ ] amazing so accessibility this
damn word has been the biggest point of
debate over the last few months in
December one of Dark Souls twos lead
developers said that he wanted the game
to be more accessible big mistake
immediately everyone panicked many
people even the biggest content creators
interpreted this as a step backwards for
the Soul series interpreting it as a
movement away from the hardcore nature
of the game in my video covering that
interview I expressed concern over the
word but I ended up giving the developer
the benefit of the doubt based on some
of the other things he said
so I'll just explain what I mean by that
easy games are accessible games by
definition but accessible games aren't
limited to being easy accessible just
means that they are easier to get into
and the soul series is guilty of being a
game that hides features from its
players we even like these features I'm
still learning new things about Dark
Souls years later however when core
mechanics like humanity summoning world
tendency and covenants aren't explained
well in game you have a problem when you
have to go to a wiki to learn about
these things properly you have a problem
it breaks immersion to have to look
these things up the soul series should
have simple controls and gameplay on the
surface and depth and nuance for people
who
more experienced at the game the same
goes for the law I don't mind having a
more obvious story on the surface as
long as the game retains its depth by
making the core concepts difficult to
understand you run the risk of
alienating a player who would otherwise
love the game if he just took two
minutes to look up what those things
meant and it just so happens that this
is exactly what the developers meant
when they originally said let's make the
game more accessible all they wanted to
do was make the core gameplay clearer so
that everyone can play along just long
enough to experience the deeper gameplay
concepts here's some quotes from the
interview that confirmed this players
will be able to take their experience
from Dark Souls 1 into Dark Souls 2 core
gameplay remains the same the combat
system in Dark Souls 2 will remain the
same based around simple control and
trial and error while Dark Souls has
simple controls there's a huge element
of depth to those controls and while
there is trial and error
there are usually clues and ways to
prove yourself so you don't just rely on
trial and error when you come out with a
sequel you try to add on new features
from software doesn't want to add on new
features for new players they want to
emphasize the core underlying concepts
so that those concepts can be
effectively expressed to the new players
this is so new players can also
experience what they're trying to
communicate so not necessarily
accessible but simply make it more clear
in terms of what we want to express with
the underlying concepts within Dark
Souls so hopefully those comments put to
rest your fears regarding the
accessibility of the game as I stated in
my December video the people are from
software know what lies at the core of a
Souls game here's a few more snippets
that really drive that point home around
five minutes into the 12 minute gameplay
reveal the enemies showcase different
reactions and thought processes based on
the actions of the player there's an
emphasis on the player having to
strategize to proceed and in the 11th
minute the director goes on to state
that death is still a core part of Dark
Souls in fact he wants to enhance that
giving a huge variety of deaths to
experience and here's a final quote from
the IGN interview regarding the law
there were fears that the story would be
dumbed down and easy to understand but
it appears that this will not be the
case two minutes into the Q&A video the
director states that spiritual elements
to Dark Souls and the Soul series in
general is the way we story tell
we want and encourage players to look
into the key details of the game and
imagine the game for themselves create
your own story as you play through the
game and interpret to yourself we will
continue to provide this feature and
that my friends is good news for my
channel and in closing around five
minutes into the Q&A the director states
that he thinks there's two underlying
concepts to the soul series one there's
a sense of satisfaction from overcoming
difficulty this is an overlying concept
we want to maintain and two there is a
loose connection with other players
throughout the world this is going to
carry over into Dark Souls 2 now this is
all great news I'm sure you agree that
the developers are trying to enhance the
core of the game which in my opinion is
the best way to go about making a sequel
no one likes drastic difference in a
sequel and if you enhance the essence of
what makes a game unique then everyone
wins in an interview with Miyazaki for
games but he confirmed that Dark Souls 2
will protect the core experience overall
I was pretty impressed with the
interview as well I'm glad that the
interviewer 5gn clearly knew what he was
talking about and he asked all the right
questions however I should mention that
I Gian weren't the only people to get
exclusive interviews the following
information is less known but no less
important most of my face for Dark Souls
2 before this interview came from Namco
Bandai Namco Bandai are the publishers
of the game and they were rumored to be
behind the decision to change the game's
directors now naturally people assumed
that this meant they wanted to change
the direction of the game as well the
publisher developer relationship is an
interesting one and it's worrying when
the publisher has more power because
they may try to push money making
decisions on the developer without
proper understanding of how that would
impact the game however I even had this
fear put to rest when I read this
interview by now gamer comm the article
reads as follows we feel that the
relationship between from software and
Namco
is good Turner Mira told us Namco Bandai
gives us lots of freedom in terms of
what we want to create and we add from
software are really able to pursue what
we want to deliver to the fans so the
relationship there is great the last
point I bring up has more to do with the
PC version of the game I play primarily
on PC and this news is particularly
heartening in an interview with shock
news you Eaton amira admitted that the
PC port of Dark Souls was not very well
done and sort of half-assed this time
around there will be more priority on PC
this time PC will even be considered and
developed from the very beginning now
Dark Souls PC was originally a port from
the console versions of the game however
this time it's actually going to be the
other way around in a translated
interview from game called calm the
developers state that the PC version
serves as a base from which it will be
adapted to consoles obviously they'll
still be developed on console separately
but it's interesting to know that this
is the case Dark Souls 2 will run at 60
frames per second on PC and a guaranteed
stable 30 frames per second on console
Dark Souls 2 won't be a next-gen console
title but it is using an entirely new
engine developed from the ground up from
A to Z in closing here's a picture of
the box up with something truly glorious
there is no games for Windows Live logo
insight this isn't a hundred percent
confirmed but it's looking pretty likely
sounds like it's time to upgrade your PC
stay tuned for more Dark Souls analysis
and next up is the gameplay
you